hey yo what's happening it's 38 special
man trust come first man rochester new
york make sure y'all check me out on the
bootleg kev podcast trust
booklet cat podcast
special guest in here
cyrus can we get this man
a nice ash trap
right there's one right there let's get
him an ashtray all right we got 38
special in here yes sir 38 special we
have to provide you with an ashtray for
the fire weed that you have been given i
appreciate that it is some great weed
man yeah my guys highest giraffe [ __ ]
right now yes i am
welcome man
it's good to see you bro uh first of all
i just want to salute you man i've been
a fan for a long time you've definitely
been uh
grinding over a decade i feel like
definitely what are we talking 15 years
now about that yeah about 15.
what because what year did you have to
go sit down was that like
damn that was 2009 2009 or some [ __ ]
yeah oh no yeah yeah yeah um was it hard
when you cause like i feel like you were
buzzing and obviously you had to go sit
down that was horrible man hell yeah it
was [ __ ] hard you almost feel like
there was like a was there was there uh
something positive you could have took
out of that like maybe you weren't ready
for the
for the shine that was coming at the
time back it was yeah looking back now
definitely i had a lot more living to do
you know i mean a lot of more ex things
to experience i had to get more of an
understanding of business
i realized i ain't want to come in the
game that way yeah you know i'm saying i
didn't want to be that kind of artist
you know i wanted to come into the game
a certain kind of way which was going to
take a certain kind of route certain
type of time
so look i didn't know that at the
beginning
you know i wanted to get right to where
i was going right then and then skip the
steps yeah but the steps you got to do
that [ __ ] to make sure that you you know
is solid when you get there yep so did
you feel like um because i feel like
sometimes uh artists make a
mistake when they're kind of like one
foot in one foot out on the rap [ __ ]
where it's like
did that force you to kind of really
focus on music more take it a lot more
serious when you got out of course like
i had to make a conscious decision and
[ __ ] like what did i want to do
and uh
prior to me making that decision i
always
gave most of my energy to the streets as
opposed to
music
you know even like the titles of your
early projects were like right yeah it
was all you know out on out on bail in
custody
right [ __ ] like that 38 laws of powder
but
yeah i'm high as [ __ ] what was the
question
i was just i was just saying like you
know
obviously
a lot of artists come into the game and
they have one foot in one foot out like
i feel like sometimes you you have a
humbling experience like getting locked
up where you know might maybe kind of
reprioritize how you see things yeah of
course man i see it like a lot of them
off a lot of people i could cuss right
yeah of course so a lot of [ __ ]
is running around taking extreme risks
and [ __ ] like that because they never
suffered any consequences
you know the younger you are the more
wilder you are moving recklessly because
you know you really ain't experiencing
any consequences and [ __ ] me i'm a
person that experience consequence after
consequence
which makes me appreciate
not having to face consequences
you know i'm saying 100 so until you
experience those consequences you're not
going to have that same appreciation
level
so you know i definitely have a high
appreciation level from
suffering from those consequences you
know i'm saying and um
i had to make a conscious decision like
i was saying
to either take music 110 percent and
give it a go and lead out over [ __ ]
alone which was a very hard decision
because i wasn't in the best position
financially right and that easy money is
easy money right yeah and what you know
is what you know yeah and that's where
the sacrifice come in
you know and i made those sacrifices and
it was the best thing that i the best
decision i made for my life
you know i'm saying and i made it just
by having faith not really having a
complete understanding of how i was
going to capitalize or liquidate but i
knew the upside potential as opposed to
the upside of potential of the streets
right the potential is like short-term
gain but the alongside the long-term
[ __ ] is jail death right incarceration
we know the results from that right it's
no it's not you know and you know
the short-term payoff is great yeah of
course of course you know what i'm
saying but
you know um
that other life meaning like the music
and the music money
just seemed a little more intriguing
and it's not there's no uh there's
really no one way to do it and i feel
like you've done a great job of carving
your own way of making
like i feel like most artists look at
the music industry as okay i'm gonna get
in advance
i'm gonna put out music and i'm gonna
tour i'm gonna go to clubs i'm gonna do
shows as opposed to really turning over
every rock if you have a core fan base
that's there's ways to monetize that it
really is and [ __ ] that's what she
if i was still in the streets i wouldn't
magnify those opportunities but i mean
not being in the streets i've already
seen that and noticed it right so it
left up when i was in the streets and
relying on other areas
you know it's easy to leave rocks
unturned you know i'm saying so it's
like okay let me go in
and figure out how to make some money in
this area in this area in this area
because it's all i have yep i have no
other way and sometimes you got to put
yourself in those positions to where oh
you got if you're a hustler then you got
to put yourself in a position to where
you know
you have to hustle you got to look at
your product i mean as much as like it's
art but it's also like a business you're
in the music business and i feel like
especially as an independent artist it
almost expands the way you can make
money if you're assigned to a major
label there's so much red tape anything
you want to do that's where you could do
whatever the [ __ ] you want
you could drop a project for three
months before it hits dsps and only your
fans get it you could drop a [ __ ]
limited edition vinyl run you could do
it there's so many things you could do
that i figured that out later on right
but at the beginning of the journey that
don't that's not too like you know
visible of course of course you know
what i'm saying so your first your goals
change as you get more knowledge and
stuff at first i just wanted to do yeah
of course of course yeah get your
advance get high advanced and stuff back
then that was like definitely still a
hard radio error that was kind of the
way to go back then it was definitely
the goal like and i didn't understand
that you know you didn't need a lot of
fans in order to really like get rich
facts you know you just need you just
need you need more fans and followers i
would take 500 fans over a million
followers i would definitely take that
because 500 fans when i say fans of
people who will spend money with you
you'll be able to pay your bills you'll
be able to keep a roof over your head
with those 500 people if you do it the
right way of course yeah yeah of course
of course you've built weight i mean
you're you're you're up there man you're
killing it uh um but yeah it's wild
because i do feel like like when i when
you talk to people who've been locked up
they take it as one of two ways either
one they come out and they're [ __ ]
more they're institutionalized or
they get humbled and it kind of corrects
the the path when you were when you were
in incarcerated
um
were you working on your bars in there
hell nah nah
me man i only could move off energy and
real life events right i can't really
like you were like unmotivated
yeah i don't even write on what i'm
doing yeah with my life doing so i'm
either i want to write about being in
jail
i knew my [ __ ] was natural talent and
when i came home
that um
i was gonna be able to work and actually
when i came home you know i i stepped my
[ __ ] up even more you know what i'm
saying if i was my flow and all that
without having to practice in jail it's
just a natural thing but i ain't working
on nothing yeah was there like a was it
like a scene in prison of like rappers
like people were like hit kicking
ciphers and then obviously you had a
name when you were in there did people
know who you were yeah
were they i'm sure they found out
a couple of [ __ ] was knowing
who i was and [ __ ] because i was still
on the come up there right you were
still on the come up yeah so i but i
would run across a couple spitters and
[ __ ] like um
shout out to my homeboy iron sheik he
was on the battle scene and him had a
few sessions in
a in a yard shout out iron chick yeah
shout out to iron sheik and [ __ ] man you
know what i'm saying
facts
um you uh
for people who don't know i feel like a
lot of people
if it wasn't griselda they discovered
benny through you guys through you and
you and you guys doing the early collab
tape was that 2015 yeah like the trust
tapes and stuff like that all that early
[ __ ]
um
explain your relation obviously both you
guys are from upstate mm-hmm about an
hour apart buffalo rochester 45 minutes
out um
explain how did you and benny end up
initially linking up
um i i used to go to dj shea studio
brush and piece rest in peace the dj
said i used to go there to record
that was like that was benny home studio
and uh like green and team invasion
shout out to green lantern and team
invasion they
they suggested that i go out to buffalo
to recall at shakespot so you know early
in my career like 2007
i would go out there and just start
working on my early mixtapes right and
then me and benny would just collab
because that was his home studio so
eventually it became my home studio as
well
and that's how me and benny gain that
relationship because i'll come through
there and we just be working and [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying and uh that's
how i started that's how i met ben
that's how i met conway and you know the
whole the whole griselda [ __ ] yeah i
think you guys are synonymous with each
other both of those movements you know
in terms of like
what y'all do with the fans which i'll
do on the business side like and then
obviously musically i think you guys are
very tied in man um has it been it's
been pretty dope for you just knowing
benny since back then to kind of see
everything
benny been one of my main motivations on
my journey and [ __ ] because it was times
that
you know on my journey i faced so many
things that would discourage me from not
really you know knowing
how to
capitalize off it that i would take
breaks right
and uh
watching benny he just would keep going
would keep going and uh
that was the motivation i needed right
so when i seen like the response he was
getting
that motivated me
it was like oh i know it's possible you
know there's somebody i work with all
the time and i see how they responded to
them so it's like oh let me show them
what i could do too
if if benny ain't keep working
the way he did i wouldn't have had that
motivation or inspiration to really keep
going because
like i said
i wasn't making no money off of it
after doing it for 10 years right so you
know once i seen my boy doing
actually getting the respect
and the recognition it was like oh okay
we own or something now and that's when
i picked my pen back up and we did a
stabbing shot that was a great project
appreciate that yeah great project it's
dope because i like to see i s like
watching you go on your recent run
and watching ransom go on his recent run
has been dope to see
and uh you know ransom somebody who's on
your new project yeah but he's also
somebody who i feel like you know
is um
has done a really good job of
finessing the independent game to your
left like using like the positive
because you know some like you said when
you first came into the game you're
trying to get a record deal i think
ransom is somebody who like
is doing a great job of
making sure he's super serving his fans
making sure he don't he don't go too too
long without making sure you hear a
project from him or you stay on top like
you know what i mean so it's dope to see
yeah both of y'all from that era right
you know really i feel like y'all are
really catching your stride right now
like it's kind of crazy it is crazy you
know what i'm saying it's it's really
it's it's it's motivational
inspirational to the people that's
grinding to let you know not to give up
because there's chapters of every of
your guys's careers
that are like
legendary within themselves you know
what i mean so it's like just to see
10 12 13 14 years in both of y'all are
[ __ ] hitting your peak it's like it's
it's dope and like you said it is
inspirational i'm sure for a lot of
artists who can watch and just be like
damn these dudes is
really hitting their stride right now
all these years later
yeah we got to stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our folks at my
bookie ladies and gentlemen
[ __ ] nfl season is approaching
it's my favorite time of the year god
damn it it's good times and the rams
versus the bills is happening kicking
off the whole regular season and there's
no way to get ready for that regular
season like getting ready for that
winning season all right i'm talking
about putting some other [ __ ] money
in your pocket you could be a veteran
better like me or you could be a first
time better and you just want to get a
little taste of the action my bookie has
got you because right now they got that
double deposit bonus if you sign up at
mybookie.ag
right now go to my bookie it's quick and
easy let's say you put 250 bucks in you
get 500 to gamble with that's right it's
a double deposit bonus but you have to
use the promo code bootleg b-o-o-t-l-e-g
it's also in the description of this
video you can just click the link and
you're in there so go to mybookie.com
use that double deposit bonus by using
the promo code bootleg you got to
register today use it and let's get this
nfl season [ __ ] cracking i'm talking
listen i don't even know the line of the
rams bills game it's about a week out on
some change away depending on the [ __ ]
you're watching this but
bill's money line what are we doing all
right my bookie sign up use that promo
code bootleg right now and get that
double deposit bonus if you put in a
thousand dollars you get two thousand
dollars to gamble with you put 100 you
get 200. it's that [ __ ] easy my
bookie go run it up let's get back to
the interview would you say that um
like obviously
you you said benny was a big inspiration
but like just the you know i feel like
you and you and griselda have similar
business models in terms of yo when we
drop we're gonna have the merch we're
gonna have the vinyl we're gonna make
sure
that fans can show up and support us
with where it counts like you might not
pay for the project but hey we got it we
got a hoodie we got a t we would you say
that like
with what griselda kind of did i don't
know who was doing that first but now on
on the merch side and that whole thing
that was definitely risotto they they
they helped introduce the whole formula
to how to actually capitalize and shout
out to gun because guns are [ __ ]
messed up shut off the gun like and
that's another thing like you know if
gunn
ain't really do what he did you know i
wouldn't had a motivation to really take
it serious as well i had to really see
that it was money to be made and really
see how to really connect with the
people and gonna figure that out you
know i'm saying father is like how to
actually capitalize on the fan base and
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying
so so so shout out to the whole rosetta
so yeah yeah that that
that that whole formula is is it that
whole independent formula started you
know with them over there yeah you know
i mean fire is that way yeah of course
like definitely definitely 100 um
you also uh you know you're no stranger
to doing collab projects shout out to my
guy chase fetty who's been through here
you guys had a dope project together um
who is on your radar that like if you're
there's like a up-and-coming artist that
you're just [ __ ] with they're like if
you could do an album with them who
would it be this that you respect
oh man let me see man because
it could also be og just somebody who
you're like man if i could do something
with this person it'd be crazy
man i would love to produce an album for
the girl a z
a-z yeah
i would love to produce an album for a
you know i'm saying
brooklyn's finest shout out az man shout
out to the god you know i'm saying as
far as new new people you know i mean
like i pretty much work with everybody
new that i'm that i'm feeling man you
know what i'm saying and uh
you know i mean the the the newest
people followers that i'm feeling like
who is applying pressure lyrically
would have to be like shayna
you know just off of the simple fact you
know i have worked with her and see how
she held her own yeah you guys got
records for sure you know and you know
she she held her own with every single
one of us from ransom benny to me and
you know we we we swing you know what i
like is uh he was on the bsf album he
was just up here uh i like goatee the
real too i like ot too yeah he got like
too you got some real uh
he'd be saying [ __ ] in a way to be
hidden that makes sense so shout out to
ot man uh okay so seven shots is out um
for you when you like look at a year
right let's say we we're january 2023 do
you automatically know what the year is
looking like like i'm gonna put this out
this out this hour you just kind of go
with the flow in terms of like release
schedule or like like
it depends on [ __ ] how much i've been
working a year prior you know i'm saying
if i've been working a year prior then
yeah you know what i'm saying like um
this year i didn't really have it
figured out last year i took a break
from uh
from the right-hand side and focused
more on producing an executive producer
so i really ain't have i wasn't really
like just going to work like i usually
would do when i write you know i'm
saying i usually would go make a record
put it to the side go make records put
it to the side but i went all that time
without doing nothing before seven shots
yeah so i didn't really know when i was
gonna drop this yeah i just woke up one
day hit my engine and was like yo let's
lock in and we went to the studio and i
recorded the whole hour and that day the
whole whole album that day cause i
recorded the whole it's eight records
yeah eight records yeah i mean so one
day yeah i recorded the whole album that
day that's [ __ ] crazy you know what
i'm saying that yeah and it was a feel
it was a feel like i like to provide a
feel so you know when that's how i
record i like to capture
the energy of that time
you know what i'm saying and record
everything while i'm feeling that energy
and that's why the project sounds like
that sonic
for you um there's like obviously guys
like yourself guys like rock marcy who
will executive bruce or produce a whole
album for somebody else like what is the
approach
for when you put your producer hat on
and how does it differentiate from when
you are the artist
uh well
my producer had i'm basically
more or less like a coach
right i'm just sitting there like just
watching
and and there to actually like
critique not really just you know like
just to actually help form whatever it
is and make sure it's the best right you
know i'm saying as a producer
i'm not really you know and um
you know it's it's
i actually enjoy that a little a lot
more than than than than me how then the
artist uh you know what i'm saying being
the coach yeah you know what i'm saying
like you know what i mean but um
you know that's that's i have to put a
lot of time into that
when i'm in that mode you know just like
on the on a business side when i'm in
business mode i'm in business mode i
really ain't thinking about writing no
raps or nothing like that you know i'm
saying that when i'm in production mode
i'm
banging out 20 beats in a day you know
what i'm saying so it'd be certain hats
when i'm in rap mode like right now i'm
rapping i didn't produce one song on
seven shots because i'm rapping
you know so i took the producer hat off
and i'm gonna tell people yeah and i'm
just rapping you know appreciate y'all
watching but listen our partners at blue
chew they got you handled fellas and etc
whatever you are they got it if you got
a dick blue chew is for you because they
will make sure your dick performs at all
time levels i mean like lebron his first
three seasons with the heat type levels
i mean your wife will thank you for it
everybody will thank you for it [ __ ]
even if you just take a blue chew and
jerk your dick it's a it's a stronger
jerk i swear to god
stronger [ __ ] jerk for sure you're gonna
be beating your dick like i stole
something
so what you got to do is go to
bluetooth.com right now
use the promo code bootleg right now and
you're gonna get your first month free
and this is the great thing about blue
chew the same active ingredients as
viagra and as cialis
but you don't got to go to the doctor's
office yeah who wants to go hang out at
the doctor's office and be like hey doc
you got some [ __ ] pills for me nobody
wants to do that no you sign up at blue
chew use the promo code bootleg and
you're getting your first month
delivered to your door
in discreet packaging i'm telling you
you're going to thank me later all right
if you've gotten blue too already just
dm me tell me just
just dm me no photos just tell me how
you know let me just tell you it's
[ __ ] amazing our producer cyrus's
daddy 70 took the blue chew he's [ __ ]
just beating down all the senior citizen
[ __ ] available in arizona right now so
go to bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg or just hit the link in the
description of this video let's get back
to the interview uh rochester obviously
upstate new york in general um
up until the last maybe seven eight
years i feel like you know
very slept on i mean you were probably
were you locked up when emilio started
to pop a bit when breaking point came
out i just came home and [ __ ] i just
came home around that time and [ __ ] but
yeah because when i think of rochester i
think of you i think of him i think a
green lantern yeah that's how it started
yeah with the whole hip-hop scene you
know what i'm saying i remember having
the team invasion mixtapes back in the
day exactly shout out to team invasion
selling them out to swat meet
shout out to green lantern like green
lantern was like
the og
of the town that really like opened
doors like that let us know like okay oh
yeah eminem's dj jay-z's dj nazis dj
right you know and one of the coldest
producers right and
people don't understand like man i used
to sit under green and study a lot
like that's how i know how to put a
project together i i you know i know i
understand it like how i would want to
start and how i would want to make it
end and like you know that come from
like you know really sitting there up on
the green green lantern has got my
favorite mixtapes ever probably and uh
he's probably he's probably my favorite
mixtape dj of all time to be honest man
so shout out to green that's my dog
shout out to green he's out in my
hometown now nazi doing his thing man
word up green lantern man so i was gonna
say was it um
did it work against you not being from
new york city or being from the city in
that area at first it definitely it just
started working for me yeah that ain't
become cool until you know
recently these last couple years right
before then
they ain't they wasn't jacking that it
was so hard like you know i mean like
new york is real like
territorial mm-hmm
prideful yeah you know and that where
they rep like you know they
so it's like
they ain't even really like supporting
other boroughs
yeah no it's like the bronx right yeah
100 alone another five six hours away
right you know what i'm saying serious
driving they never even heard of before
so
it was real hard
for them to like understand where we was
coming from
you know i'm saying they didn't
understand it because
you know they didn't understand that you
know these were stories up here and
people really getting busy up here right
they never been up there or never went
to the prison system mm-hmm you know
what i'm saying so you think it's it's
that's gone away recently
hell yeah like
if i was the understanding yeah i feel
like you know if they understand now
like like you know yeah it's another
part of new york because i feel like
there was always guys like you know
obviously static select is not from new
york he's from boston but i feel like he
always would show level 65 uh just to
the guys like you know the grizzled guys
that's when i first heard of them was on
static freestyle um caselay you know
definitely but i feel like now you know
you'll see funk flex show support you
know and obviously shout out to conway
for motivating flex to challenge every
new york rapper
to make new music
i'm glad something dope came out of that
situation because it looked interesting
at first shot somebody got conrad but um
for you man like uh
in 2022
when you put out a project
what is the like checklist it's like
okay the album's gonna come out we gotta
have the merch together we gotta have
the vinyl together like what is
everything that you you gotta make sure
is put together before you put a project
out because like we said you're a
hustler you know how to really ultraly
monetize your work your art
for independent artists that are
watching this like what are the things
that you make sure are all aligned
before you put something out i make sure
that the project is you know i make sure
i got i make sure it's done and i got
all the assets first you know assets
meaning like
my good artwork social media stuff
social media stuff videos
things that i could do that i could use
to help with my rollout you know i make
sure i got all of that before i go and
hire a publicist or somebody to help me
work it cause you don't want to hire the
publisher before everything is chasing
your tail and stuff like that so the
first thing i do is make sure i got all
the assets connected to the project
after i got that then i make sure i got
all the merchant stuff you know in
production mm-hmm
and then um
that's about it man once i got all those
things lined up you know i make sure
that i'm with a good distributor to make
sure i could get some
proper visibility on right maybe some
playlist pitching you know what i'm
saying
which is very important
and uh
that's about it once i got those things
in the you know i don't you know i make
sure i turn the music in
at least 30 days or more prior to me
releasing to give the digital peoples
enough time to do what they need to do
with it like you can't just like us
sometimes all this we lock ourselves
into a date be like i want to drop next
week just get them the music and stuff
you know you want to actually really
turn stuff in you know and then come up
with a date yeah because if you've come
up with the date and the album's not max
mix master turned in then you like you
said you handcuff yourself to a day and
right for artists who don't know like
you definitely want to turn your [ __ ] in
30 days prior for the dsps at least at
least you know at least you know what
i'm saying so yeah that's that's about
that what like how does somebody get
vinyl made
is that is that it's hard as hell right
now because i heard it's really tough
it's hard as hell right now man so if
you it's like backwards right yeah man
so listen
vinyl is like gold man you know
yeah i get you all good piece of
fighting them things going up in value
they are people are collecting them and
they're going to start collecting them
shout out to the collectors man y'all go
on these on ebay and stuff y'all gonna
see some pieces of vinyl in there
that's selling for thousands of dollars
and [ __ ] like that man you know so
when i get ready to drop seven shots
y'all make sure y'all stand in line and
get a piece of this because it's only
gonna be a limited amount and you know
they ain't gonna do nothing but go up in
price and it's like you know all other
valuable things we gotta stop the
interview tell you about our partners at
odd socks well first of all let's check
out the brand new collab
look at these
the bootleg kev sock you see my pink ass
face on those [ __ ] socks nobody wants
to buy those we're gonna figure out a
way to give them away though uh but look
odd socks the most comfortable socks in
the world um and the best thing about
odd socks is they're our family man i've
been rocking with these guys for about
10 years now and i will not wear
anything else on my feet like i swear to
god i'm about to take my shoe off i'm
about to take the look what is this
it smells great too that's an odd sock
right there that's awesome basic you
know what i'm saying we [ __ ] with odd
socks you should too they got the crazy
licenses we're talking about nickelodeon
shout out to patrick [ __ ]
cheez-its
baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick
what do we got in here
come on man
yeah a little pop-tart underwear yeah i
mean
yeah these are the odd socks basics all
right so if you go to the website right
now order you some underwear order you
some socks use the promo code bootleg
kev that's one word all together bootleg
kev and you will save 20 off at checkout
go to
oddssocksofficial.com one more time
that's oddssoxoficial.com
promo code bootleg kev and you will save
20 off your order of course we're
presented by odd socks and we are proud
to say so all right let's get back to
the interview
removing
your project and any projects you've
been a part of from this year what is
your favorite album what's your album of
the year so far 2022
oh [ __ ] man man i mean
what did i listen to this [ __ ] man
damn man i don't want [ __ ] on give me
like three of them i don't listen to
people how about that you didn't listen
to the pusher t album nah it's fire i
gotta go listen to it what about
kendrick do you listen to the kendrick's
album definitely i heard not i heard i
heard like what was on the radio like
with him and the chick going back and
forth i thought that [ __ ] was oh him in
the chicken i didn't go listen to it
though i'm kind of weird when it comes
to music right i gotta have like i'm not
i'm real i don't know bro i'm a little
weird and [ __ ] when they come to me i
don't listen it like that's fair you
like that what about who would you
consider your top like four or five like
you're personal i don't got to be the
greatest of all time i'm talking about
just like your personal favorites just
mc's all time
oh coogie rap i put at the top of the
list yeah obviously you the rest of
these ain't in no order but g-rap start
first you know and yeah you've obviously
got music dedicated to him shout out to
cool g rap
um [ __ ]
whole
not just from lyrical content from from
from the fill everything everything [ __ ]
it yeah
oh
nice for creativity mm-hmm
[ __ ] rewind man like creativity like
i got different rappers that's for
different things
tupac for emotion
pain yep that was the first person that
made me feel something like how i feel
sad or i feel happy i feel tupac
from pain
um
one more
more huh
damn
big
big and without a doubt big for just
like
flow
the best flow effort flow butter flow
right big for flow mm-hmm
period like that's fair yeah that's a
great five shot cools you rap too man
don't get enough flowers out here
honorable mention big pun
pun man honorable mention
punishment oh my god yeah that's one of
the biggest the biggest whatevs i'm like
man what a pun would have never passed
man [ __ ] where would he be at right now
i mean [ __ ] biggie and tupac we could
say that about all three of them right
now [ __ ] a whole different landscape of
this whole game bro that's a fact it'd
be insane man what do you got coming uh
do you have anything else coming the
rest of the year or anything on the
books more music or you just working
seven shots
right now i'm working seven shots but i
got some [ __ ] i don't know if i want to
announce it yet because i don't know
when it's coming but what i can announce
and tell y'all that me and conway
did an album during the pandemic oh
yeah is it coming out it's coming out
2023 y'all get ready for that has conway
convinced you to visit him in denver yet
no i didn't go out there yet he's pretty
much living there now i went and saw him
uh last month oh wow
he [ __ ] fell in love with denver and
it's just not like he's just not leaving
i gotta go i never even been i gotta go
check that [ __ ] out you've never been to
denver
just go out there conway's got like a
he's got a sewed up out there they treat
him like he's you would think he's from
denver we're just moving around at the
strip club [ __ ] weed grows all kinds
of [ __ ]
so conway and special album 2023 facts
love to hear it yeah there it is man i
appreciate you pulling up uh
go yo you just also just did crazy
freestyle which is a different youtube
video go watch that [ __ ] that [ __ ] was
insane
um
what is the website people can go
support the trust station the
trustation.com y'all could go get merch
y'all could go and get vinyl
y'all could go and listen to my own
radio station on thetruststation.com
y'all could go and listen to my radio
station you're you're curating the
playlist i'm curating the playlist man
but you all know i got some shows in
there too you know i'm saying that um is
live as well and [ __ ] you know i mean
the app will be launching soon y'all
gonna be hearing you're gonna have the
app coming definitely the app is coming
soon so people will be able to ride
around and listen to your radio station
right from their phone yeah well right
now you can still do it you can go to
the trusted dot com from your phone and
listen to it right from the site from
your browser but the app is on the way
oh i mean big things coming man
you're gonna be dropping like exclusive
music on the app first hell yeah yeah
that's smart bro oh yeah there it is man
38 special appreciate you pulling up
brother yeah you having me bro fire yes
boom